Hi, I'm Craig and this is Crash Course Government
and Politics and today we're gonna talk about
parties. Woo! Yeah! No, not those kind of
parties. We're talking about political parties,
which can be a lot less fun. Woo.
[Theme Music]
So, today we're talking about why we have
political parties and the role of parties
in American politics. But before we dive into
the pool - some would say a cesspool - that
is political parties, let's have a definition.
Political party: a team of politicians, activists
and voters whose goal is to win control of
government. So kind of an important point:
the goal of a party is to control government
and in the U.S. that means electing people
who agree with and usually are members of
the party. So above everything else, parties
exist to win elections. Parties don't mainly
focus on influencing policies, although particular
policies are often associated with particular
parties. Influencing elected officials is
mainly the job of interest groups, who we'll
talk about soon. For now, let's keep in mind
that political parties and interest groups
are not the same thing.
So let's look at three reasons why we have
political parties. One: I dunno. Two: I dunno.
Three: I dunno. I do know, I'll tell you in
a second. First, we create political parties
to facilitate collective action in the electoral
process. Given that parties exist to win elections,
this is probably the main reason we have them.
But what does facilitate collective action
in the electoral process mean exactly? Basically,
it means that parties make it easier for voters
to form groups that will vote in certain ways.
Here's an example, albeit one that overgeneralizes
a little bit. Just come on, just go with it.
In general, republican candidates support
policies that are more friendly to business,
so if you're a businessman, you know that
affiliating yourself with the republican party
is probably going to benefit you.
The second reason given for forming political
parties is that they facilitate policy making.
This reasoning applies to elected members
who being to political parties, not to voters.
So membership in a party allows politicians
to work together. It's easier for democrats
to form alliances with other democrats and
sometimes these alliances have the added benefit
of strengthening the party. Party affiliation
can help legislators from different places
work together. For example, common republicanness
should make it easier for a republican from
rural Kansas to work with another republican
from suburban Florida. Sometimes though, party
ideology can prevent even members of the same
party from working together as happened in
2008 when republicans couldn't agree on whether
the government should bail out struggling banks.
A third, and I must say not altogether convincing
reason why we have political parties is to
deal with the problem of politicians' ambition.
According to this idea, parties provide a
structure, maybe even a career ladder for
politicians so that they're not always acting
in their own self interest. The fact that
the party provides different leadership possibilities
and some sense of discipline prevents ambitious
politicians with largely similar views from
competing against each other, like say 16
candidates running for president all in the
same party. Just wouldn't happen. Ever.
So that's why political parties exist, but
what do they do? Well, they have five main
functions in the U.S. and I'll leave it up to you
to decide which - if any - is the most important.
Eagle doesn't get to decide.
Eagle doesn't get to decide anything.
So here's the list: 1. Recruit candidates;
2. Nominate candidates; 3. Get out the vote;
4. Facilitate electoral choice;
5. Influence national government.
The first thing that parties have to do if
they want to win elections is find candidates.
This is a two-step process involving recruiting
and nominating. We've already mentioned that
in order to be a good candidate for office,
you generally have to have an unblemished
personal record - like me - or at least be
really good at heartfelt apologies. I don't
have an unblemished record and I'm very sorry
about that. Also, you need the ability to
raise money. Of course, in order to avoid
any problems with campaign financing, it's
helpful to have money yourself, but why spend
your own money if you can convince people
to give money to your campaign? Maybe print out
some hats. Merch works, merch helps raise money.
There are lots of people who want to run for
office, although there's some debate about
whether we're really getting the best candidates.
The pay isn't great and neither is the prestige
anymore, and then there's the scrutiny that
a run for office puts you and your family
through. Parties play an important role in
sifting through all the people who want to
run and picking those who have the best chance
of winning. Nomination is the process through
which a potential candidate is actually chosen
to represent a particular party in an election.
When we talk about nominations in the US,
we're mostly talking about the presidency
because that's the only office that goes through
the formal nomination process. But technically
congressman and senators are nominated by
their parties to run as well. There are three
ways that a candidate for president can be
nominated. In the old days, presidential candidates
were nominated at a convention or caucus,
which are gatherings of party members governed
by rules. Conventions still occur every four
years but they're largely ceremonial these days
because presidential candidates are actually nominated
during the primaries. Let's go to the Thought Bubble.
Primary elections are held to choose candidates
who will then run in the later general election.
Political parties decide when and how primaries
will be held and who the candidates will be.
These are the elections that pit democrat
against democrat and republican against republican
to see who will face off in November. Primaries
can either be open or closed. Most states
have closed primaries, which means that only
registered voters of a particular party can
vote in that election. So, in a state with
closed primaries, like New York, only democrats
can vote in the democratic primary. And since
in many districts one party is overwhelmingly
dominant, the primary winner is very likely
to win the general election too. In states
with open primaries, members of any party
can vote in the primary, which sounds great
because it encourages more participation but
it also opens up opportunities for mischief
*evil laughter*. For example, if there's a
strong republican candidate up against a weak
republican candidate in a state with open
primaries, democrats can turn up and vote
for the weak republican in the hopes that
if he wins he will have less of a chance in
the general election running against a democrat.
Sneaky.
In presidential elections, the winner of a
primary election will be assigned a certain
number of party delegates. Delegates are non-elected
party members who actually nominate the candidates
at the convention. The delegates are usually
pledged to vote for the candidate who won
the primary in their state, at least on the
first ballot, and majority rules in nominating.
This is why we see so much election coverage
of primaries and why some states like New
Hampshire try so hard to have their primaries
early. Once a candidate has sewn up enough
delegates, he or she becomes the nominee,
and the convention serves largely as a formality.
Although the primary system is more democratic
than the convention, it still has problems.
Even though there's more opportunity for participation,
that doesn't mean people actually participate.
In fact, only about 25% of those eligible
to vote in primary elections actually do,
and these tend to be the more ideologically
extreme members of the parties. Because to
them, winning elections matters most. So,
if only partisan voters show up, we tend to
get uber-partisan candidates. And because
they have to win bruising primaries before
they even get to the general election, these
candidates tend to be aggressive and uncompromising.
That's good when you're competing in an election
but not so good when you're trying to work
with other people to craft policies or, in
very rare cases, legislation. This is why
many people think that primaries add to
political polarization in the US.
Thanks, Thought Bubble - you got my vote.
There's a third way that a person can become
a candidate, but it's a long and dangerous path.
Hey, Stan, zoom the camera in as I say that.
It's a long and dangerous path *evil laughter*.
A person can run as an independent
and if they get enough signatures on a petition,
they can become a candidate. You're more likely
to see this in congressional races but even
then it's not super common. It's also really not that
long and dangerous as we implied in that last shot.
The third thing that parties do is mobilize
voters, also known as getting out the vote.
This is pretty obvious because you can't elect
a candidate if you don't get people out to
vote for them - duh! Parties get out the vote
through direct mail, email and advertisements,
and they can also help with voter registration
drives. The main thing the party does in terms
of getting out the vote is coordinate volunteers
to help encourage voting. If you want to help
on a campaign or with an election effort,
your local party office is a good place to start.
Another good place to start is getting out of bed.
Getting out the bed is a campaign we should have.
Parties also help to facilitate electoral
choice. Basically, a political party acts
sort of like a brand. So, knowing which party
a candidate represents acts as a kind of shorthand
for voters in the same way that seeing, say,
a Netflix logo lets you know that you're about
to chill. I'm not going to go into what each
party stands for right now but let's just
say that knowing that a candidate is a republican
or a democrat allows you to figure out pretty
much what they stand for even if you don't
know anything about the candidate. Political
parties even help non-partisan voters by narrowing
down political choices and making things easier.
If you want to, you can choose a candidate
by answering two relatively simple questions:
which party better represents my interests and
values, and which candidate belongs to that party?
Finally, believe it or not, political parties
have a role in the way the national government
actually works. Party membership is really
important in Congress. Parties determine who
the Speaker is since he or she always comes
from the majority party and is chosen by a
vote of members of that party. Parties also
determine the composition of the committees
and party leaders assign members to those
committees. And parties help determine who
the chairs of the committees are and they,
along with the Speaker and the majority leader
in the Senate, largely shape Congress' agenda.
The president and his party have a reciprocal
relationship - that's the best kind of relationship
and the most fun to say. Reciprocal. The president
is the leader of his party and his personal
character and popularity helps to shape the
party's brand - for better or worse - and can
be used to raise money. On the other side, the party
throws its support behind the president's initiatives and
helps to elect candidates that support him in Congress.
So, at their most basic level, parties exist
to elect political candidates and thus gain
control of the government. In order for them
to do this well, they need to provide voters
with clear electoral preferences and encourage
them to act on those preferences. In a way,
this branding function - helping voters to
choose between Candidate A and Candidate B
- is what parties are all about. But you're
free to disagree and if you do, go form your
own party and do whatever you want. It's a
party! Woo! Thanks for watching, see you next time.
Crash Course Government and Politics is produced
in association with PBS Digital Studios. Support
for Crash Course US Government comes from
Voqal. Voqal supports non-profits that use
technology and media to advance social equity.
Learn more about their mission and initiatives
at voqal.org. Crash Course is made with the help
of all these hard-line partiers. Thanks for watching.